is it hard to land on an asteroid
is this uh is this is this a dumb
question
it feels like uh it would be
quite difficult to actually operate
a spacecraft in such a uh
dense field of debris
oh the asteroid belt um there's a ton of
material there but it's actually not
that dense it is mostly open space
okay uh so so mentally do picture like
mostly open space with with some rocks
uh the problem is some of them are not
thought to be
solid so some of these asteroids
especially these these core mantle
fragments you can think of as sort of
solid like a planet
but some of them are just kind of
aggregates of
material we call them rubble piles and
so there's not necessarily
might look like a rock but do a lot of
them have kind of
clouds around them like a dust cloud
thing
or like do you know what you're stepping
on when you try to land on it
like what are we supposed to be
visualizing here
this is like very few have water right
there's some water in the outer part of
the asteroid belt but they're not
quite like comets okay um
in the in the sense of having clouds
around them there are some crazy
asteroids that do become active like
comets that's the whole other
category of thing that we don't
understand um
but they're surfaces i mean we have
visited some you can
you know find pictures that spacecraft
have taken of them we've actually
scooped up material off of the surface
of some of these objects we're bringing
it back
to analyze it in the lab and there's a
mission that's launching
next year to land on one of these
supposedly
core fragment objects to try to figure
out what the heck
it is and what's going on with it but
the surfaces
you know they're they're you can picture
a solid surface with some little grains
of sand or pebbles on it
and occasional boulders maybe some fine
dusty regions dust kind of collecting in
certain places
you